(slogans)
- "Pain, travail et liberté" :
une quarantaine d'Afghanes
ont manifesté contre
les restrictions que
leur impose le régime taliban,
bien conscientes
des risqus.
Ce matin, elles ont défilé
devant le ministère de
l'Éducation pour réclamer
justice et la fin
de l'ignorance.
Sur leurs banderoles,
des références au 15 août,
qu'elles qualifient
de "jour noir". C'est la date
de la reconquête de Kaboul
par les talibans après
le retrait précipité des forces
occidentales l'an dernier.
La réponse des talibans
ne se fait pas attendre.
(rafale de tirs)
ne 5 minutes après
le début de la marche, un groupe
de combattants les dispersent
en tirant dans les airs.
(rafale de tirs)
En un an, le gouvernement
islamiste a progressivement
sapé les libertés que
les femmes avaient acquises
ces 20 dernières années.
La dernière restriction
remonte au mois de mai.
Depuis, les femmes doivent
obligatoirement porter
le voile intégral en public,
la burqa de préférence.
"Éducation, travail,
timentaire :
nous faisons face à tellement
de défis que je ne sais paspar t
cette adolescente de 16 ans.
En un an, les femmes ont perdu
le droit de fréquenter l'école
secondaisont exclues
de la plupart des emplois
publics et, souvent,
les premières licenciées
dans le secteur privé.
"Combien de temps
devons-nous souffrir ainsi?
dit cette ancienne policière.
Combien de temps les femmes
doivent-elles rester assises
chez elles? Nous mourronsde cet"
Privé de l'aide internationale
qui portait le pays à bout de
bras, l'Afghanistan fait face
à une grave crise humanitai hum.
Selon l'ONU, plus d'un Afghan
sur deux vit dans une situation
d'insécurité alimentaire
et plus de la moitié des enfants
de moins de 5 ans souffrent
de malnutrition aiguë.
C'est aussi la dure réalité
contre laquelle se battront,
coûte que coûte, des groupes
de résistantes courageuses,
jusqu'à ce que leur dernier cri
soit entendu.
Ici Louis-Philippe Trozzo,
Radio-Canada, Mon